it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week the hunter becomes the
hunted with alien isolation this takes
place 15 years after the original film
so you play as ripley's daughter amanda
hiding from a xenomorph you can run you
can hide you can throw flares and you
can even use a flamethrower to keep that
gruesome death that keeps roaring its
ugly head from getting to you
live the ridley scott nightmare october
7th well if that game gave you anxiety
this should calm you down a bit it's
candy time halloween is approaching and
so is the sequel to the much beloved
costume quest this semi-rpg adventure
encourages you to complete quests build
your party and collect adorable costumes
along the way and it allows you to
transform into awesome superheroes like
pterodactyls chubby clowns and the clear
winner thomas jefferson with his
declaration of destruction attack
trick-or-treat october 7th but what if
you wanted to play a fun and
light-hearted cartoon game but you
wanted to like pay a lot more money for
it well you're in luck because
skylanders is out with a brand new game
with shocking new skylanders to collect
chaos is back and he just released a
whole bunch of baddies from cloud
cracker prison
only you the portal master can trap all
those nasties and put them back where
they belong in a minimum security
facility
hit the atm october 5th
also this week we get behind the wheel
with drive club it's showing off 11
tracks and 10 fancy cars but focusing on
communities you can ride or die with
your best buddies
also clearly focusing on being
incredibly good looking as you can see
here drive together win together october
7th
and finally this week nba 2k15 comes out
to play a tribe called quest has picked
which nba game they're going with have
you because it's already going to be
pretty obvious who the winner is
get your dunk on october 7th for further
details visit gamespot.com release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change see you next week